[MUSIC PLAYING]
IDO GREEN: Hi.
I'm Ido Green, a developer
advocate for Actions on Google.
Did you know that building
apps for the Google Assistant
can reach users on
million of devices?
In this video, I'm
going to show you
how to get more users to your
app for the Google Assistant.
There are four ways for users
to get your app for the Google
Assistant through
explicit triggering,
implicit triggering, discovery
in the Google Assistant
Directory, and clicking on
the Assistant Directory link.
Let's go deeper on each one.
Users can invoke your
app by explicitly
asking for it by name.
When you submit
your app, you could
provide a list of
triggering phrases
that when combined
with your app name,
will be recognized as a
request to use your app,
such as OK Google,
talk to Bitcoin info.
You could also talk with an app
and ask for a specific action
in one sentence.
And yes, it supports
deep links, so when
users ask for your app
to perform something
in particular, for
example, OK Google,
ask Bitcoin info for
the current price.
Here are some good examples
of explicit invocation
in the console.
Remember, multiple
samples help the algorithm
to do a better job of
steering people to your app.
So use a few examples.
Another way for users
to invoke your app
is by implicit triggering.
This type of invocation occurs
when a user asked the Google
Assistant to perform a
task, and the platform
decide that your app
has an action that can
complete the user's request.
Here's an example
using Dialogflow.
In Dialogflow, your actions
and the invocation phrases
are defined as user
says expressions
for triggering intents.
Here, we're providing
some phrases
that would trigger the Ask
Bitcoin info app to get
the current bitcoin price.
Make sure to keep
your action invocation
phrases specific to
the app use cases
and build phrases to include
both verb and an object.
And if you want to learn
more about Dialogflow,
please visit Dialogflow YouTube
channel for great videos that
will teach you how to
use this powerful tool
for natural language processing.
If a user asks to play
a game, the Assistant
may offer them a few options
from the apps available.
This is another other
way as a developer
to tell the Assistant
what your app can do.
Users can discover your app
for the Google Assistant
through the Google Assistant
Directory, a great place
to explore all available apps.
Users don't have
to install anything
in order to access the
Google Assistant Directory.
You could reach it
inside the Assistant app
by clicking at the
top-right button.
It will show you all
the different apps
for the Assistant
that are available.
Finally, driving users to
your app directory page
will give them a chance to try
it out, rate it, and share it.
This mean even more users.
You can hyperlink to your
app's Assistant Directory page
and promote it just
about everywhere.
Share it in social media, blog
about it, create an ad banner,
or offer it to users from
your current services.
That was it.
Now you know four
great ways to get
your app discovered and used.
Please check out the YouTube
description below for links
and learn more about
invocation and discovery.
Until next time, be strong
and create amazing apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]